federal health officials are preparing
to unveil some new thinking on covet 19
and specifically how schools across the
country should respond to potential
student infections new guidelines appear
to abandon or in some cases just relax a
number of recommended past practices
as students go back to class cbs news
has obtained a copy of the cdc's draft
document expected to ease covet 19
guidelines controlling the spread of the
virus
michael osterholm is an infectious
disease expert this virus is going to be
here with us
in the days ahead and we have got to
learn to live with it while the
guidelines are not final yet we're
learning some of the proposed changes
de-emphasizing six feet social
distancing and removing the so-called
test to stay recommendations in which
students exposed to kova 19 take regular
tests to stay in the classroom the cdc
is going to say we should go back to
school
relatively normally with minimal
restrictions
then count me in michael cornell a
superintendent in western new york says
his students need to get back to normal
what we have to focus on is making sure
our kids experience joy value and
connection in school another possible
change unvaccinated people exposed to
covenant 19 will no longer need to
quarantine instead masking for 10 days
and testing five days after exposure
the proposed changes are raising some
concerns with less than half of
school-aged children fully vaccinated
and the majority of americans living in
communities with high rates of covet but
ostrom says the virus is still evolving
as this virus continues to
change over time we might be revising
these guidelines again